تغيَّر المشهد بشكل جذري
يعني مبدأ المعركة لدى السعودية كان مستمر
في عهد الملك عبدالله ومستمر في عهد الملك سلمان
لكن طريقة إدارة الحرب اختلفت
ليش؟
لأن الأمير محمد بن سلمان عنده رؤية تجاه هذه القضايا
قال باختصار أنا أريد إصلاح علاقتي
مع إيران ومع تركيا ومع أمريكا ومع العالم
عندكم خيارين
الخيار الأول، نوصل لاتفاق مشترك
لكم مصالحكم ولي مصالحي
خلونا نلعب على المصالح المشتركة
ما تبغون هذا السيناريو، فالمواجهة هي المصير
الأمير محمد بن سلمان عندما دخل هذه المعركة
هو يُدرك أنها معركة كسر عظم
ويُدرك أنَّ هذه المعركة خطيرة عليه وخطيرة على القارب
أو القيادة التي يقودها لأنها مواجهة كسر عظم حقيقية
هذه المعركة عندما تدخلها ستدخلها وحيدًا
بس يجي يقول لك دخلنا في حرب مع أو في عراك مع إيران
وفي الأخير بعد كل هذا رجعنا للنقطة الأساسية
اللي بدينا عليهم فما تغيَّر شيء
دخلنا مع قطر وخرجنا وما تغيَّر شيء
دخلنا في حرب مع اليمن علشان نُنهي الحوثي ولا يزال الحوثي موجود
بشار لا زال هو الرئيس ونحن تهاوشنا معه
ففي الشكل العام، وين المكاسب؟
أهلًا، هذا فنجان من ثمانية
وأنا عبدالرحمن أبومالح
كيف تفكر الرياض؟
هو موضوع الحلقة هذه وهو مهم
وحاولت ألقى شرح موضوعي ما استطعت
لقراءة التحركات السعودية من عام 2015 وحتى اليوم
ليه كانت فيه فترة خصومات وصراعات ومعارك متتالية وقوية؟
وليه الآن صارت فترة مصالحات تهدئة وإنهاء الخلافات؟
قد يحمل هذا الانتقال من خصومة تركيا
ومقاطعة إيران وقطر وحرب في اليمن وتوتر شديد مع أمريكا
إلى اتفاق العُلا والمصالحة السعودية التركية والمصالحة السعودية الإيرانية
وعودة سوريا إلى الجامعة العربية وتعزيز العلاقات الصينية
هذا كله قد يحمل تفسيرات وتحليلات كثيرة
ضيفي يعطي تحليلًا يستحق الاستماع إليه
هي حلقة تقرأ وش اللي حصل في الرياض عام 2015؟
يُربط بسياقات هامة تبدأ من عام 1940 حتى عام 2003 إلى 2008
اللي يرى ضيفي أنها نقطة مفصلية وشرارة بداية الربيع العربي
وبفهم هذا كله تستطيع أن تفهم
كيف وصلنا إلى المشهد السياسي العربي اليوم
ضيفي في هذه الحلقة العزيز مالك الروقي
صحافي ومحلل سياسي
معه ستستمع إلى طرح مختلف وتحليل جدير بالاحترام
قبل أن نبدأ، في هذه الحلقة كثير من الروابط والمصادر
اللي أشار إليها ضيفي، وكثير مهتم لهذه المراجع
لكن دائمًا توترني سالفة أننا نحطها في وصف الحلقة
لأنها غير مرتب ويمتلئ ويصير غير مفيد
فحببت أجمعها في مكان للمهتمين
ففي وصف الحلقة رابط الاشتراك لنشرة فنجان البريدية
تصل لبريدك لحظة نشر الحلقة الصوتية صباح كل أحد
إذا مهتم بالمصادر والمعلومات المهمة في هذا السياق ولم تُنشر وبعض الكواليس
اشترك في نشرة فنجان من خلال الرابط الموجود في وصف هذه الحلقة
أما الأن لنبدأ
وش تصورك العام؟
إلى؟
للحلقة هذه
أنت وش تصوّرك؟ أنا قلت لك تصوّري
أنا تصوري مفترض نشرح شيء بسيط جدًا
للناس اللي ما عندها سياق للأحداث
للناس اللي مالها خلق تتابع نشرات أخبار
ولا لها خلق تشوف كلام مكرر أنه نحن قويّين
بس وليش نحن قويين؟ ليش نحن
عطني سياق واضح منطقي، سياق الأحداث وش اللي صار؟
هل فيه أخطاء ما في أخطاء؟ هل فيه أشياء جيدة وأشياء مو جيدة؟
يعني السياق المنطقي اللي يخاطب عقول
أعتقد إنه هذه الدائرة العامة
والسياق رغم أنه مهم بس إنه هل تغيرنا ولا ما تغيرنا؟
هل تغيرنا وما تغيرنا هذا مرة مهم لأنه نحن ما تغيَّرنا
أنت تتوقع ما تغيَّرنا؟
مرة ما تغيرنا، أبدًا ما تغيرنا، نحن معيارنا واحد من يوم بدأنا
من يوم بدأنا، ركز
والله يا أخي أنت شكلك في الشركة الإبداعية معهم
بس ليه تتوقع إنه ما تغيّرنا؟
نحن بدأنا؟
الحين بدأنا
نحن ما تغيّرنا لأنه إذا تبغى يا عبدالرحمن تفسر شلون تفكر الرياض
في التعامل مع سياستها الخارجية
لازم ترجعني إلى عهد الملك عبدالعزيز
جميل
ليش نرجع إلى عهد الملك عبدالعزيز؟
نرجع يا طويل العمر للحرب العالمية الثانية
شلون تعامل معها الملك عبدالعزيز؟
وأيش كان معياره الأساسي اللي بنى عليها
سياسته الخارجية وتعامل مع القوى الموجودة وقاعدة تتصارع في العالم
عندنا 1940 قُصِفت الظهران من قِبل القوات الإيطالية
وتعطل النفط السعودي يا طويل العمر لأشهر
هذا بالنسبة الملك عبدالعزيز اللي للتو
اكتشف النفط وبدأ النفط يُغدق خيراته على البلد
فجأة توقّف والملك عبدالعزيز عنده مشروع تنموي يبغى يطوّر البلد
يبغى يصنع بلد بمعنى أصح مو يطورها
وعندك العالم منفجر
وش الحل؟
الحل يا طويل العمر أنه يتواصل مع الإيطاليين والألمان
أرسل مبعوثة
خالد الهود القرقني على ألمانيا
وطبعًا اللي بيرجع للتاريخ يلقى صور ومقاطع فيديو
لخالد الهود القرقني يوصل إلى برلين
ويقول للألمان الحرب هذه إحنا مالنا دخل فيها
حربكم مع الحلفاء
ترى مالنا علاقة، هذه الحرب لا ناقة لنا ولا جمل فيها
وهم في الأساس ليش قصفوا الظهران؟
هم قصفوا الظهران عشان يعطّلون القوات
البريطانية الموجودة في المنطقة
ويعطّلون إمدادات النفط لها
وبالتالي الملك عبدالعزيز شعر أنه أنا قدام خطر
بدخل في معركة وأنا مالي صلاح فيها
المعركة كانت قريبة في الشرق الأوسط، وشلون؟
في مصر مثلًا معركة العلمين كانت قائمة وموجودة
الملك عبدالعزيز يشعر أنه المعركة قريبة من عنده
في نفس الفترة هذه الملك عبدالعزيز اتخذ القرار هذا
رغم أنه نظريًا هو على علاقة جيدة بالبريطانيين
على علاقة جيدة بالأمريكان
هذا قبل الاجتماع الشهير مع روزفلت، على الأقل كان فيه توافق
هنا الملك عبدالعزيز اتخذ هذا القرار
بعدها بفترة نرى رشيد عالي الكيلاني في العراق
شخص قرر إنه يقاوم القوات البريطانية في العراق
رشيد عالي الكيلاني بدأ انقلاب في بغداد
وبدأ يا طويل العمر يدعم هتلر بشكل رسمي وهتلر يدعمه
فاقتربت أيضًا المعركة من الملك عبدالعزيز في ذاك الوقت
الملك عبدالعزيز التزم الحياد في هذا الموضوع
رشيد عالي الكيلاني لما فشل الانقلاب حقه وين لجأ؟
لجأ للملك عبدالعزيز بن عبدالرحمن
ورغم ذلك البريطانيين كانوا في ذلك الوقت
يصرون على الملك عبدالعزيز أنك لازم تسلم
هذا الخائن المارق الذي انقلب على الملكية في العراق وأيَّد هتلر
فلازم تسلم هذا الرجل
الملك عبدالعزيز رفض التسليم رغم أنّ الملك عبدالعزيز لا يمتلك ذاك الوقت جيش قوي
يستطيع مواجهة بريطانيا أو يستطيع مواجهة الحلفاء
بعد فترة التقى السفير الأمريكي بالملك فيصل
أيش تفسيرك لعدم التسليم؟
عدم تسليم إنه أنا عندي موقف محايد طبعًا
بجيك في السياق تفسير الموضوع هذا
الملك فيصل لما قابل السفير الأمريكي
في جدة سأله السفير الأمريكي وطالب أنه يجب أن يسلم رشيد عالي الكيلاني
الملك فيصل رفض ذلك وفق الوثائق الأمريكية الموجودة في المراسلات اللي كانت موجودة
فالملك فيصل قال لو ما بقى واحد من آل سعود ما راح أسلّمه
نشوف بعدها بسنتين تقريبًا أو ثلاث سنوات
مو من حادثة رشيد عالي الكيلاني
بعد سنتين من قصف الظهران
شلون بدأت معايير القوى الدولية تتغيَّر
والحلفاء ينتصرون، وبدأت العالم يتشكّل
جاءوا وقالوا بنشكّل عصبة الأمم، فبالتالي الدول اللي راح تدخل
معنا في عصبة الأمم يجب أن يكون لديها موقف من الحرب
وتُعادي ألمانيا وإيطاليا
السعودية في ذلك الوقت
التقى الملك عبدالعزيز بروزفلت في البداية، الرئيس الأمريكي
واتفق معه أنه حلفنا تجاري
الآن بيننا وبينكم أنتم يا الأمريكان ونحن يالسعوديين
هذا الحلف ليس حلف تبعية إنما حلف تبادل مصالح
بعدها بكم يوم التقى في تشرشل في مصر
لما ألتقي في تشرشل أيش يقول المترجم
اللي كان حاضر معهم في ذاك اليوم كمترجم للملك عبدالعزيز
وظهر في وثائقي أعدته دار الملك عبدالعزيز؟
يقول إنه الملك عبدالعزيز عندما اجتمع في تشرشل
قال له أنا كنت مساهم في هذه المعركة
أبغى نتيجة مساهمتي
كسبي أو غنيمتي من هذه المعركة وهذه الحرب
لأني أنا المملكة العربية السعودية
منعت القوات الإيطالية أنها تكون موجودة على البحر الأحمر
طبعًا البريطانيين عندهم علم أنه
الإيطاليين طلبوا قبلها بسنوات من الملك عبدالعزيز
أنهم يقيمون قواعد عسكرية في البحر الأحمر
عشان يواجهون التواجد البريطاني
وقدّموا مساعدات وما إلى ذلك
الملك عبدالعزيز اتخذ موقف الحياد
فمعيار الملك عبدالعزيز الأساسي عندي مصلحتي
وين بتكون مصلحتي أنا بكون معها، اللي هي مصلحتي الوطنية
لكن هذه المصلحة ما تؤخذ بالفكر البراقماتي البحت
اللي ما عنده موقف أخلاقي تجاه القضايا
أنا بأتبع مصلحتي، لكن أيضًا عندي بعد أخلاقي اشتغل عليه
فالملك عبدالعزيز لما جاء رشيد عالي الكيلاني اتخذ موقف أخلاقي
منطلق هذا الموقف الأخلاقي عادات وتقاليد العرب
إذا دخل الدخيل سِلم
بناءً على هذه العقدة اللي أنت شايفها
تقدر تقيس موقف المملكة العربية السعودية في كل مراحلها
وممكن تكون أبرز حادثة ممكن تفسّر لك
التقارب ما بين موقف الملك عبدالعزيز في الحرب العالمية الثانية
اللي هي قضية النفط اتفاق أوبك بلس
شلون تعاملت أمريكا؟ شلون تعاملت روسيا؟
شلون تعاملت السعودية مع المشهد بهذه الطريقة
وقدمت مصلحتها وقالت مصلحتي أولًا
كذا أعتقد أنك تقدر تفهم السياسة السعودية من هذا المنطلق
تمام، فإذن لو تبغى تصفها تقول أنها سياسة تهتم لمصالحها؟
بس هذا وصف عام جدًا
أيش النمط اللي موجود من عهد الملك عبدالعزيز إلى الآن؟
نمط؟
النمط للسياسة السعودية اللي أنت تبغى تقول أنه ما تغيَّر
أوصفه لي
أنا أقول إنه
أو عرِّفه
أعرِّفه؟
أنا ممكن أرجع لك يا طويل العمر
إلى كل المواقف اللي مرت بتاريخ السعودية
السعودية لم يكن لديها موقف يومًا ما ضد مصالحها في تاريخها
تمام
فإذا تبغى تعطيني موقف ضد مصالحها
فأنا أقول لك نعم، المعيار ليس معيار المصلحة
ممتاز؟ عكس دول موجودة في المنطقة
مثل؟
ما أبغى أعطي أمثلة
تمام
تمام؟
دول كثيرة في المنطقة
النظام السياسي يقدم شيء لمصلحة دولةٍ ما
على حسابه؟
على حساب شعبه وعلى حساب وطنه ومصلحته الوطنية
أنا أقول النظام السياسي في المملكة العربية السعودية
منذ عهد الملك عبدالعزيز إلى اليوم
وهو يُقدّم مصلحة الوطن، المصلحة القومية
المصلحة الوطنية على مصالح الدول الأخرى
ليش؟ لأنه يأخذ شرعيته من الداخل ولا يأخذ شرعيته من الخارج
في عهد الملك فيصل مثلًا كيف إنه تغيَّرت الفكرة
وصار الإسلام هو السلاح اللي تجي تبغى تستخدمه السعودية
قبلها ما كان موجود
كيف تتغير هذه الأشياء؟
كيف تقدر تقرأ التغيرات في استخدام الأسلحة؟
هذه اسمها أوراق سياسية
بمعنى كل دولة من الدول أول شيء تُحلل وضعها الداخلي
تحلل قوتها الداخلية بناءً عليها
تقرر أنها تلعب بالأوراق السياسية الموجودة في المنطقة
العالم العربي عبدالرحمن اليوم مترابط بشكل غير متخيل
اليوم لما يسقط طفل في المغرب داخل بئر
تلقى واحد في بيشة يحط حالات واتس أب عن هذا الطفل
واحد في الدوادمي وواحد في عسير
كلهم مهتمين بقضية طفل طايح في بئر في المغرب
بينما لو هذا الطفل طاح في البرازيل ما بتلقى نفس التفاعل معه
أنا أبغى أعكسها على الجانب السياسي
العالم العربي 1902 لما دخل الملك عبدالعزيز لإستعادة الرياض
كان العالم العربي كله محتل من قبل القوات الاستعمارية
العراق، الأردن، بلاد الشام أغلبها احتلال بريطاني
سوريا، لبنان احتلال فرنسي
مصر، السودان احتلال بريطاني
شمال أفريقيا تتكلم عن ليبيا، إيطالي
تتكلم عن المغرب، الجزائر، موريتانيا، تونس فرنسي
في اللحظة اللي خرج منها الاستعمار
العالم العربي كله تحول إلى الملكية
ملكية في مصر، ملكية في العراق، ملكية في سوريا
حتى لو كان وقتها قليل، ملكية في الأردن
الملكية السنوسية في ليبيا، الملكية الموجودة في المغرب
فتحوّل العالم العربي، الملكية في اليمن
تحوّل العالم العربي إلى ملكيات
عندما حدث ثورة جمال عبدالناصر أو انقلاب جمال عبدالناصر
بناءً علي أيش موقفك منها
تحوَّل العالم العربي إلى جمهوريات عسكرية
جمال عبدالناصر
نتكلم عن عبدالكريم قاسم في العراق
نتكلم عن الضباط في سوريا
نتكلم عن القذافي وانقلابه على الملكية
نتكلم عن حالة انقلابات، فجأة صار العالم العربي كله عسكر
حتى الملك حسين بن طلال وهو ملكية
ما استطاع أنه يقاوم هذه الموجة من العسكرة وهو ملك
اضطر أنه يلبس الزي العسكري
اللي أبغى أوصّله أنه السعودية لما صارت
حالة العسكرة عسكرة العالم العربي قدّرت الموقف
ما هو الموقف اللي أنا الحين قاعد أحافظ؟
أو وشلون أحافظ على وجودي كدولة متماسكة في ظل هذه الحالة من الانقلابات
والتدخلات العسكرية الموجودة في العالم العربي؟
طبعًا إذا نبغى نفكك صراع الملك فيصل وعبدالناصر
صراحة راح نأخذ وقت طويل
لكن إذا لك خلق تسمع فممكن
أبد تفضّل
عبدالناصر لما وصل أول طرف حاربهم الإسلاميين
وهو الإسلام السياسي وجماعة الإخوان المسلمين بشكل واضح
جماعة الإخوان المسلمين بعد تعامل عبدالناصر معهم
انتقلوا إلى دول الخليج والمملكة العربية السعودية بدرجة أولى
خصوصًا بعد إعدام سيد قطب
هذا السيناريو حدث في العراق
بقمع الإسلاميين في العراق، وقمع الإسلاميين في سوريا
قمع الإسلاميين في ليبيا، في تونس
هؤلاء كلهم وجدوا الملجأ الوحيد لهم
دول الخليج والمملكة العربية السعودية
السعودية كان تعاملها مختلف، السعودية كانت تقول تعالوا بس بشرط
أن لا تتدخلوا في السياسة الداخلية السعودية
هذه الحالة من التكدُّس اللي تعرَّض له الخليج
جعلت من هذه الحالة ورقة قوة تستطيع المنطقة، منطقة الخليج إنها تواجه المد الناصري
طبعًا هذا كان أيضًا مدعوم من قِبل أمريكا
اللي كانت ترى إنه وجود الحالة الدينية في العالم العربي
راح يقلل من النفوذ الشيوعي والنفوذ السوفيتي
فبالتالي هذا أيضًا يُعطي على قولتهم الدافع أيضًا المهم
إنه ريقن كان يطلع ويخاطب المسلمين يقول
نحن وياكم أديان واحدة
خلونا نُعادي الملاحدة الشيوعية الحمراء
فكان الخطاب العام بشكل عام اتجاه إلى جعل الحالة دينية أكثر
هنا بدأ على قولتهم الصراع يتخذ منحى أخر
السعودية ترى بأنه هي قائد العالم الإسلامي، فلذلك
بس معليش، يوم خرجوا من مصر والعراق وغيره
هل كان خروجهم إلى الخليج
لأنه المكان الوحيد ولّا كان استقطاب من الخليج لهم؟
لا لا، لأنه هو كان المكان الوحيد
فكان النتيجة أنهم موجودين
والدليل أنه هو كان المكان الوحيد وليس استقطابًا
هذولا أغلبهم السياسيين راحوا يشتغلون في التعليم
صاروا مُدرِّسين
رجل راعي برلمانات وأحزاب في مصر، في سوريا، في العراق
ينتقل من الأحزاب إلى أن يصبح مُعلم
مُعلم في قرية، معلم في مدينة معلم
هذا يعطيك الدليل أنه الخليج ما استقطبهم
هم جاؤوا لجوءً إلى الخليج
فبالتالي الخليج حاول يستخدمهم بهذه الصورة العامة
من ناحية تأمين الجبهة الداخلية ضد المد الناصري
الإعلام لعب دور لا تتخيله يا عبدالرحمن في الصراع الناصري الفيصلي إن صح التعبير
مثلًا جمال عبدالناصر عنده إذاعة صوت العرب
في السعودية عندنا إذاعة نداء الإسلام من مكة
عندنا حاول جمال عبدالناصر أن يُسيطر على جامعة الدول العربية
رغم أنه الجامعة السعودية من مؤسسيها في أيام الملكية
فالسعودية أبرزت كذلك دور التضامن الإسلامي ومنظمة التعاون الإسلامي
ورغم ذلك السعودية دخلت تدعم جامعة الدول العربية
تقول أنا بالورقتين هذه أنا قوية
أنا بالعروبة أنا قوية لأني أنا مهد العروبة
أنا بالإسلام قوية لأني أنا أيضًا مهد الإسلام
فبالتالي الورقتين هذه
هي أوراق قوة سياسية بالنسبة لي ما أحد يقدر يأخذها مني
وبناءً عليها أنا قاعد أصون مصالح الأمة العربية والأمة الإسلامية، من هذا المنطلق
فهذا اللي يفسر لك
ليش السعودية اتخذت هذا الموقف؟
هو بناءً على واقع سياسي لازم تلعبه بهذا الدور
طيب ليش أنا أجيب هذا بالضبط المثال؟
لأنه يعطيني برضه ليش إنه الناس تقول هذه الفترة تختلف
فمثلًا المسألة الإسلامية صارت أقل استخدامًا في الخارجية السعودية
وتقدر تشوفها في كثير من الأشياء
الدعم وغيره صار مختلف تمامًا في السنوات الأخيرة
اثنين: مثلًا السعودية في تاريخها ما بدأت حرب
بس بدأت حرب مؤخرًا، فالقصد هو أقدر أجيب كم مثال
بس القصد أنه يبدو أنه هذه الفترة مختلفة
وش اللي تغيَّر؟
إذا أبغى أجاب على هذا السؤال لازم أرجع لعام 2003
2003؟
نعم 2003
حسنًا تفضَّل
وأبغاك تعطيني وقت إني أعطي على الأقل السردية
اللي من خلالها نستوعب شلون المشهد في العالم العربي تغيَّر؟
لأني مؤمن بأنه الأخبار اليوم إذا شاهدها المشاهد العادي
لن يستوعب قيمتها وأهميتها مالم يفهم سياقها
وهذه أزمة الأخبار اليوم في القنوات التلفزيونية
فإذا ما فهمت سياقها ما راح توصل إلى المعنى الحقيقي للأخبار
خصوصًا إذا تعتمد فقط على نشرات الأخبار، ما تقرأ الصحافة
ما تعرف التفاصيل الأكبر في الصحافة
فبالتالي يصبح عندك فهم واضح
أبغى أرجّعك إلى عام 2003
2003 يا طويل العمر نتكلم عن القوات الأمريكية قررت أنها تغزو العراق
حط إيقاف على المشهد وشوف الخريطة
وش هي خريطة التحالفات الموجودة في العالم العربي؟
عندنا يا طويل العمر إيران ليس لديها نفوذ في المنطقة
ليش؟ لأنه فيه حجر أصم اسمه العراق
على عداء مع الجميع
على عداء مع السعودية، على عداء مع إيران، على عداء مع تركيا
هذا الحجر الأصم كان عبارة عن حجر سد مأرب
اللي لو طاح هذه الأمم الثلاث راح تصطدم ببعضها شئت أم أبيت
من تطوّر البناء إلى أناقة التصميم ورفاهية الخدمات مع تميّز الموقع
حلول سكنية مبتكرة ومستدامة مع شركة صفا للاستثمار
المزيد في وصف الحلقة
لما أقول لك شوف خريطة العالم العربي
شوف الدول المتحالفة مع بعضها
سوريا، مصر، السعودية كان مثلث رئيسي في التحالف العربي
وعلاقة السعودية بكل الدول العربية كانت ممتازة
جميعها ما عدا العراق
ورغم ذلك، في أواخر سنوات العراق
السعودية صارت العلاقة جيدة
لو نشوف لقطة عِزة الدُّوري لما سلّم على الملك عبدالله في الجامعة العربية
بدأت السعودية أيضًا تُحل هذا الموقف
طلعنا العراق من المشهد
جات القوات الأمريكية غزت المنطقة
وش اللي تغيَّر عندنا الآن؟
اللي تغيَّر يا طويل العمر أنه الدول الثلاث أصبحت في مكان التقاء واحد وهو العراق
إيران قررت منذ البداية أنها تلعب بأوراقها
شلون؟
افترض أنه القائد السياسي في طهران جلس قال وش هي أوراقنا اللي نقدر نلعب فيها داخل العراق؟
ورقة العروبة أنا ما أقدر العبها أنا فارسي
ورقة الإسلام هي ورقة مهمة
بس أي إسلام؟ الإسلام السني ما راح يجيني
أنا راح ألعب على الإسلام السياسي الشيعي
إذن هذه هي ورقة يا إيران راح يلعب بها داخل العراق
جاءت تركيا
نفس السيناريو صار في أنقرة
وش الورقة اللي نقدر نلعب فيها؟
ورقة العروبة ما تفيدني
ورقة الإسلام جدًا مفيدة
إذن ورقة الإسلام السياسي هي الورقة الأنجح في التعامل مع الوضع العراقي
لذلك انطلقت تركيا في دعم الأحزاب الإسلامية الموجودة في شمال العراق في الشمال السني
السعودية في ذلك الوقت كان عندها موقف ابتدائي من الغزو إنها ضد الغزو
وأعتقد أنه هذا أيضًا على لسان الأمير سعود الفيصل
أنه السعودية أخطأت بعدم التدخُّل أو حماية عروبة العراق في تلك اللحظة
خليناهم، نتكلم عن 2004-2005
2004-2005 السعودية أصلًا كانت مشغولة بالتفجيرات اللي صايرة في الرياض
والأحداث اللي نعرفها، تفجيرات المحيا وما إلى ذلك
وصلنا 2006-2007 انفجر الوضع الطائفي في العراق بشكل غير مسبوق
الإسلام السياسي السني والإسلام السياسي الشيعي تداخلوا مع بعض صار الانفجار الشهير
وهي الأحداث الطائفية المرعبة
السعودية في ذلك الوقت أيضًا كان فيها موجة عامة
تيار إسلام سياسي أيضًا يدعم مقاومة الوجود الطائفي في العراق
هذه لها ظروف، ونحن نقرأ الآن واقع سياسي، ما نبغى نقول من الصح ومن الغلط
جينا يا طويل العمر هذا 2007 الحرب الطائفية
2008 كانت لحظة مفصلية على العالم
لماذا؟ لأن صار الأزمة الاقتصادية العالمية
الأزمة الاقتصادية العالمية انهارت بسببها اقتصادات كثيرة في العالم
بما فيها الاقتصاد الأميركي، الاقتصاد الأوروبي واقتصادات آسيوية
وش أثر الأزمة هذه على المشهد؟
الأثر يا طويل العمر أنه القوات الأمريكية
أو أمريكا قالت أنا راح أقلّص تواجدي في العالم لأنه عندي أزمة اقتصادية
تتكلم عن أرقام الكونقرس الرسمية
تقول إنه الجيش الأمريكي أو وزارة الدفاع الأمريكية
تدفع في الثلاث دقائق في العراق مليون دولار في 2008
هذه الأرقام من اللي كان يسوّقها في ذاك الوقت؟
كان يسوِّقها أوباما لأنها أرقام رسمية
أوباما في انتخابات 2008 شعار حملته وش كان؟
التغيير، إنه راح نغيِّر
من أهم الأشياء اللي رفعها في 2008
قال أنا راح أنسحب من العراق
راح أنسحب من أفغانستان
راح أقلّص تواجدي في العالم
راح أوقّف المساعدات العسكرية
اللي أعطيها مصر وأعطيها الأردن
تتكلم عن مصر بعد اتفاقية كامب ديفيد أصبحت تأخذ مساعدات من أمريكا وفق الاتفاقية
أوباما قال أنا راح أقلّصها
وراح أقلّص المساعدات اللي قاعد أرسلها لكل دول العالم
وهذا طلّع موجة كبيرة في أمريكا تقول هذا الصح
نحن وش كلّفنا ندفع للصومال؟
إحنا وش كلّفنا ندفع لمصر، ولّا الأردن
ولّا نخلي أبنائنا يُقتلون في العراق ولّا يُقتلون في أفغانستان
لذلك حملة أوباما نجحت في إبراز هذه الحالة
طبعًا هذه الحالة جاءت معها حالة أخرى وجود اليمين
ظهر اليمين في حالاته الأولى
اللي سينتهي في نهاية المشهد بوجود ترامب
اليمين هنا بسبب الأزمة الاقتصادية
كانت أيضًا شعارات مماثلة لشعارات أوباما لكنها أقل ديمقراطية
كانوا يقولون طلعوا المهاجرين
ليش نفتح ديرتنا كل شوي على هالمهاجرين
ويجون يأخذون حلالنا ويأخذون وظائفنا وما إلى ذلك
طلعت لك مارين لوبان في فرنسا
نفس الخطاب فرنسا للفرنسيين وطلّعوا المسلمين من عندنا
وطلّعوا المهاجرين هذولاء، واللي عيونهم مدري شلونها
هذه الموجة راح تكبر معنا بعدين وتصير شيء كبير
2009 قرر أوباما أنه ينسحب ويسحب القوات الأمريكية من العراق
وقّع غليها نوري المالكي كأحد إنجازاته وقال أنا الذي أخرجت القوات الأمريكية من العراق
2009 بدأت شهية إيران ترتفع وشهية تركيا ترتفع
ومقاومة السعودية تبدأ بشكل فعلي
السعودية قالت إنه هذه المنطقة الآن، الإنكفاء الغربي هذا ما يطمئن
نحن إذا تركنا هذه المنطقة إيران وتركيا راح تأكلها
هذا بعدين اللي صار في أجزاء معينة
2010 وش اللي صار؟
2010 بدأ الربيع العربي
لأنه الأنظمة العربية الموجودة كان عندها كوارث إدارية
وكان عندها أزمة اقتصادية هائلة
تسببت بأن هذه الأنظمة لا تستطيع مواجهة الظروف الاقتصادية الموجودة في العالم
ارتفعت نسبة البطالة في العالم العربي 2009 بسبب الأزمة، ارتفعت نسبة الديون
حالة الفقر أيضًا ارتفعت، البطالة
كل هذه شكّلت لنا الربيع العربي
هذه هي السبب المحرك الشرارة التي دفعت الربيع العربي للاندلاع
وليست شرارة البوعزيزي لأنه أحرق نفسه
هذه الشرارة الحقيقية الاقتصادية لأنه هذه الدول لم تستطع أنها تقاوم المشهد
والبنية الإدارية والمؤسسات الحكومية ما كان عندها قدرة على الإصلاح
لأنها اعتادت على هذه الحالة من السكون
وهذه الحالة يسميها حازم صاغية «العفن السياسي»
أن فيه مؤسسات في العالم العربي تعفنت سياسيًا بس ما أحد اكتشف أنها تعفنت
لما انفجر الوضع اكتشف الجميع إنه المؤسسات هذه ماقدرت أنها تشيل البلد
شوف مثلًا في السعودية أزمة كورونا
اكتشفنا أنه عندنا مؤسسات تشيل البلد
ليش؟ لأنه عندك يا طويل العمر الأغذية ما نقصت
الكهرباء، الغاز، الطوارئ بشكل عام
عندك اكتفاء ذاتي في كثير من الأشياء اللي أنت قاعد تسويها
وعندك دولة قادرة أنها تواجه أزمة
الأزمة هذه اكشفت لك إنه عندك مؤسسات
نرجع إلى 2011، 2011 بدأت إيران
بس دقيقة لأنه 2011 برضه تاريخ مفصلي بس ودي الحين ليش أنت اخترت 2008؟
لأنها الأزمة الاقتصادية مو الحراك السياسي
مو أوباما، مو رغبة أوباما
الاقتصاد هو الذي قاد المشهد في العالم، وليس في العالم العربي فقط
هذه كلها انعكاسات
لأنه وجود أوباما لاعب في المشهد بشكل كبير فما ودي
أوباما حالة تمظهر، أوباما تمظهر
أوباما شلون قاد وشلون وصل إلى السلطة؟
لأنه صار في أزمة اقتصادية
شلون قالك حملتي هي التغيير؟
لأنه في أزمة اقتصادية
شلون دعموه؟
دعموه الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين ترى على فكرة
لأنهم كلهم يتفقون إنه لازم نغيِّر، لازم ننسحب من هالدول المتخلفة كانوا يقولون
فبالتالي هذه كل الظواهر اللي بتجيك بعدين هي ظواهر، هي حالة تمظهر
تقولي والله الربيع العربي في بعض الدول، في كثير من الدول فيه حقوق سياسية
فيه ناس فعلًا عندهم أزمة سياسية، فبالتالي انفجر الوضع
هذه كلها كانت موجودة
لكن اللي حرّكها فعليًا هي الأزمة الاقتصادية
نرجع لـ 2011
2011 يا طويل العمر الورقة اللي كانت ترفعها إيران في العراق
وقالت هذه تنفع لي الحين قالت عندي المنطقة العربية
أبغى أشوف وين الدولة اللي تصلح فيها هذه الورقة وبستخدمها
ممتاز؟ هذا 2011
عندي البحرين نزّل فيها هذه الورقة
بدأت المظاهرات في البحرين
هنا السعودية اضطرت أنها تواجه هذه الورقة بنفسها
وما تتركها زي ما صار في العراق في ذاك الوقت
لأنه ما أحسينا أنه فيه شيء راح يتغير بشكل كبير
ففعلًا قادت السعودية درع الجزيرة للدخول في البحرين ووضع حالة الاستقرار السياسي
بعدين جاء مجلس التعاون ودعمهم دعم اقتصادي كبير
للبحرين وعُمان عشان تهدِّي الأوضاع في تلك المناطق.
السعودية عبدالرحمن لو تبغى تقرأ تاريخها
يبدو لي أن الاستراتيجية الأمنية اللي قائمة على السعودية، اللي صنعتها السعودية لنفسها
أنه الدول المحيطة فيني دار ما دار هذه هي خط ناري لا يجب أن تقترب دولة معادية منه
نتكلم على الأردن، العراق، الكويت
البحرين، قطر، الإمارات، عُمان، اليمن، السودان، مصر
الأردن لما اقتربت منها إسرائيل الثقل الحقيقي للجيش السعودي كان في الأردن
العراق لما حارب خُميني
السعودية دعمت صدام حسين ودعمت العراق لكي لا يُبتلع من قِبل ايران
وايران خصم ذلك الوقت
صدام حسين 1990 عندما دخل الكويت السعودية دخلت بنفسها
في البحرين 2011 السعودية دخلت بنفسها
في اليمن 2015 السعودية دخلت بنفسها
في مصر 2013 عندما استطاعت تركيا أنها تدخل ويكون لها نفوذ في مصر
السعودية دعمت بنفسها تحرُّك الجيش المصري
في السودان حاليًا السعودية هي التي تقود أو تحاول لملمة الوضع السوداني رغم صعوبته
هذه العقلية السعودية تفكر بهذه الطريقة
2011 البحرين
2011 سوريا
إيران تستخدم هذه الورقة
2011 لبنان
2011 أيضًا بدأت الثورة اليمنية بس إيران ما كان لها ورقة قوية بذلك الوقت مع الحوثيين
تركيا طيب وش قاعدة تسوّي 2011؟
أيضًا ورقة الإسلام السياسي، ورقة الإسلام السياسي هي اللي راح تنفعني أنا في كل منطقة
فبالتالي راح أدعم الإسلام السياسي في مصر
راح أدعم الإسلام السياسي في تونس
في تونس ممثلًا بالغنوشي والنهضة
راح أدعم في شمال سوريا الإسلام السياسي
راح أدعم طارق الهاشمي ضيفنا السابق في السطر الأوسط
في شمال العراق
راح أدعم الإسلام السياسي في الصومال
راح أدعم الإسلام السياسي ممثلًا بالبشير في السودان
فتركيا قاعدة تلعب
هل تقعد السعودية مكتوفة الأيدي؟
يجب أن تقاومهم في كل هذه المناطق؟
وش سوّت السعودية؟
السعودية دعمت البحرين قلنا
دخلنا في موضوع البحرين
بعدين يا طويل العمر في موضوع سوريا، رغم أنه سوريا موضوع مشربك بشكل غير طبيعي
وملف مليء بالأخطاء ومليء بالأشياء الجيدة
ملف حقيقةً مشربك
في لبنان نفس الفكرة
حاولت السعودية تقاوم الوجود الفارسي والوجود التركي في كل تلك المناطق
وصلنا لـ 2013-2014
بدأت أمريكا تُجهّز لإرهاصات الاتفاق النووي الإيراني
2015 يا عبدالرحمن اتفقت أمريكا مع الدول الغربية
مع إيران بأنه نحن ما عندنا مشكلة تسوون البرنامج النووي
لكن نحن بنراقب عليكم
وفي المقابل نظير هذه المراقبة
راح نعطيكم أموالكم المجمدة
كم أموالهم المجمدة اللي أخذتها إيران 2015؟
عبارة عن 100 مليار دولار في 2015
100 مليار دولار عندما ذهبت إلى صندوق إيران
وين راحت؟
راحت لميليشيات في العراق 2015
راحت للحوثي 2015
راحت لميليشيات في سوريا، في لبنان
صار فيه سيولة في السوق، سيولة غير طبيعية
صار موقف إيران أيضًا موقف قوة
السعودية 2015 قررت أنها تدخل عاصفة الحزم عشان توقف مشروع إيران في اليمن
لأنها كانت مضطرة، ما عندي حل إلا هذا الحل
بس مو أزمة الحوثي قديمة مع السعودية؟
وحتى من قبل الربيع العربي؟
أنا تذكر يوم قلت لك في الربيع العربي
أنه فيه مطالب حقة بس هي ما حرّكت المشهد
فيه حد أخير أنت لازم توصل له
إذا تجاوزت هذا الحد أنا راح أضطر أتدخل بنفسي
وفيه أحداث هي اللي بتحرّك لك المشهد وبتخليك أنت لازم تدخل
2015 ارتفعت نسبة التبادل التجاري يا طويل العمر ما بين فرنسا وإيران بنسبة 50%
وارتفع أيضًا التبادل التجاري ما بين بريطانيا وأمريكا مع إيران بنسب أيضًا متقاربة
ليش اليوم فرنسا هي أكثر دولة حريصة على إتمام البرنامج النووي الإيراني؟
ليش؟
لأنه الشركات الفرنسية مستفيدة من هذا الاتفاق
في السطر الأوسط لما التقينا برنارد ليفي
وهو سياسي معروف في فرنسا ومؤثِّر، وعنده مواقف تختلف تتفق معه
كان يقول بصريح العبارة أنه الشركات الفرنسية هي التي تُحرك السياسة الخارجية لفرنسا
بمعنى اليوم ليش فرنسا مهتمة جدًا بلبنان؟
مهتمة جدًا بلبنان لأنه الشركات الفرنسية هي التي تسيطر على لبنان
لما اتفقت لبنان مع اسرائيل على قضية تنقيب النفط اللي موجود في البحر المتوسط
الشركات الفرنسية هي التي أخذت عقد هذا التنقيب
اليوم فرنسا مهتمة في محاربة الإرهاب في مالي
لأنه الشركات الفرنسية قاعدة تطلّع النفط في مالي
وقاعدة تستفيد من المناجم الموجودة واليورانيوم وما إلى ذلك
فبالتالي لا يجب على الشعب المالي أن يبقى رهينة الإرهاب
صحيح
تمام؟
وهذه الأوراق اللي تلعبها الدول
الحين لما أقول لك إيران تلعب ورقة، تركيا تلعب ورقة، فرنسا تلعب ورقة
أنت ما تقدر تروح لمالي تقول لا أنا أبغى آخذ شركاتي راح تأخذ منكم ثرواتكم
لكن أنا أقول لا أنا جايكم أحارب الإرهاب
وعلى الدول الأخرى أيضًا الحليفة لفرنسا
أنها تشتغل بنفس الشغلة، بمعنى اليوم الرئيس الفرنسي لا يستطيع يطلّع من ميزانية الدولة
ويدعم القوات المالية داخل مالي
لأنه البرلمان راح يوقّفه
ويقول ماهو بعلى كيفك تودّي فلوسنا
لكن فرنسا وش قاعدة تسوي؟
أتواصل مع عبدالرحمن، عبدالرحمن قائد لدولة سين مثلًا
أقول يا عبدالرحمن مصالحك الفلانية راح أعطيك إياها
وش المقابل؟ ادعم لي الحكومة المالية
عبدالرحمن عنده القدرة يسيطر على البرلمان، اللي عنده يقدر يحرّك الدنيا
طيب بكذا عبدالرحمن يدعم مالي، وأنا أدعم عبدالرحمن في قضايا أخرى
لذلك تشاهد وجود دول كثيرة في العالم ما لها علاقة في مالي
لكنها موجودة في مالي لمكافحة الإرهاب
الإرهاب موجود في مالي، قولًا واحدًا هذا خالصين منها
بس الاهتمام
وش معنى أهميتوا بالإرهاب في مالي وما اهتميوا في الإرهاب مثلًا في أي منطقة أخرى؟
بس مشكلة إيران أحسها إنها مشربكة ومختلفة
حصول إيران على القنبلة النووية أو أكتمال برنامجها النووي
أول شيء أنه أمريكا هي اللي أعطتها هذا الغطاء الدولي بهذا البرنامج
وأمريكا في برنارد هيكل كان يقول أنه لأنه أمريكا تبغى إيران تمسك المنطقة كلها
وهي تبغى تطلع
فمشروعها سياسي
وهذا تستفيد منه اقتصاديًا موضوع يجي بالضرورة بعده على طول
بس مثلًا فرنسا تقدر مع أي دولة ثانية، يعني عندها مصالح اقتصادية في أكثر من دولة
وإذا ارتبكت المنطقة فهو مضر لفرنسا ولاقتصاد فرنسا
فبيضر المنطقة كلها، فهي موجودة شركاتها في كل دول العالم
ممتاز بس فرنسا الآن وش تواجدها في الشرق الأوسط؟
عندها شركاتها في السعودية، عندها شركاتها
الشركة السعودية أو شركاتها في أي منطقة أخرى
أجزم إنها تطلّع فلوس أكثر من إيران
بالعكس
بعد الاتفاق النووي الإيراني فرنسا استفادت استفادة مرعبة
السوق كبير السوق الإيراني لا تستهين فيه
سوق كبير وسوق ما فيه منافس، أنت الوحيد اللي موجود فيه وقاعد تؤسس له من سنوات طويلة
بعدين لازم نفكر أنه الرئيس الفرنسي تفكيره ما يفكر
لمصلحة البلد البعيدة، هو يفكر في مصلحته الانتخابية الحالية الآن
عندي الشركات اللي قاعدة تدعمني، الحلفاء اللي قاعدين يدعموني الآن
يبغون نطوّر علاقتنا مع إيران، انتهى، هذه نقطة آخر السطر
نعم أنا يهمني استقرار المنطقة عشان الشركات تمشي وتستثمر وما إلى ذلك
لكن أيضًا بالنسبة لي إيران مهمة لأنها سوق جديدة وكبيرة أنا سأبتلع هذا السوق
لأنه ما أحد عنده قدرة أنه يدخل في هذا السوق بقدري
بس وش علاقة إيران مع فرنسا؟ أحس إنه فيه علاقة استثنائية مختلفة
زي ما هي علاقتهم مع لبنان، بس مثلًا مع إيران خامنئي كان عندهم
أي شيء سياسي يخص إيران تلقاه موجود في إيران سواءً مع المعارضة أو معه
فعلاقة فرنسا
اقتصاد
اقتصاد! من ذاك الوقت؟
باختصار، أنا مدري ليش أنت محسسني إنه الاقتصاد مرة شيء هامشي للموقف
لا لا، جدًا مهم
الاقتصاد مرة رئيسي يا عبدالرحمن
مافي شك، بس اختيارك لدولة واحدة
هو اللي يحرك أغلب السياسة اللي موجودة في العالم
مافي شك
يعني السياسية يا يحركها اقتصاد يا تحركها أيديولوجيا
يا اقتصاد يا أيدلوجيا.
الدول المؤدلجة تنهار سريعًا، الدول اللي عندها فكر اقتصادي
وتبني اقتصادها على مصالحها الاقتصادية
أو تبني سياساتها على مصالحها الاقتصادية هي دول مستمرة
لأنه المعيار عندها واضح
دامنا في إيران، أعطني مصلحة أمريكا الاقتصادية، أو هل أمريكا برغبتها مثلًا أو اتفاق أوباما
كان اقتصادي ولّا سياسي؟
أنا أعتقد شوف العقلية الأمريكية فيه أكثر من عقلية
فيه عقلية أمريكية تقول والله إدامة الصراع الموجود والتوتر في الشرق الأوسط
سيخلق فرص جيدة بالنسبة للأمريكان مع الطرفين
إدامة الصراع يعني إدامة الاستشارات، يعني إدامة التسليح
بشكل عام وجود القلق يخلق فرص
اقتصادية
الفوضى تخلق فرص اقتصادية
حالة الاستقرار هي تخلق فرص اقتصادية لمن كسبها
بس بيجي طرف جديد يدخل ما يقدر يدخل ينافس إلى أن تجي المنطقة تتنظّف، تجيها فوضى
ندخل الحين على صفحة جديدة
أنا نتكلم الحين 2015، ممتاز؟
2015 بوقّف الخريطة وأقول لك يلا شوف لي 2015 المنطقة وش التركيبة الموجودة فيها؟
التحالفات
حلو
السعودية، مصر، الإمارات، البحرين، الكويت، عُمان موقف ما له علاقة بهذا الصراع
الأردن علاقة السعودية كويسة مع الأردن
بعطيك مثال السعودية 2003-2004 لما اُحتلَّت العراق
رئيس الوزراء الأردني طلع بالتلفزيون يقول أنّ السعودية قدمت لنا النفط بلا مقابل لمدة سنتين
كدعم اقتصادي للاقتصاد الأردني كي لا ينهار
هذا يرجّعنا إلى نظرية الخط الدائرة النارية اللي حطتها السعودية
على الدول المحيطة فيها أنه لا يجب أن تسقط
يجب أن أحافظ عليها وأحافظ على حالة الاستقرار الموجودة فيها
أتكلم عن المغرب أيضًا، علاقتنا جيدة في ذلك الوقت
إيران وين التواجد الإيراني؟
2015 العراق، سوريا، لبنان، اليمن
تركيا؟
سوريا، العراق
تونس، شمال العراق، الصومال
وبقية المناطق اللي عندها نفوذ فيها
2016 تغير المشهد بشكل جذري
لأنه القيادة في السعودية تغيَّرت
المعركة مستمرة
مبدأ المعركة لدى السعودية كان مستمر في عهد الملك عبدالله ومستمر في عهد الملك سلمان
لكن طريقة إدارة الحرب اختلفت
ليش؟
لأنه الأمير محمد بن سلمان عنده رؤية تجاه هذه القضايا
قال باختصار أنا أريد إصلاح علاقتي مع إيران ومع تركيا ومع أمريكا ومع العالم
شلون إصلاح؟
إصلاح ونحن 2017  الصراع مع إيران صار أعلى شيء
الصراع مع تركيا صار في أعلى حِدة، الصراع مع
قطر
قطر مع كندا، مع، مع
هذا كله من منطلق إصلاح العلاقة
يقول العلاقة اللي بيننا علاقة مبنية على أسس غير منطقية
تعالوا عندكم خيارين
الخيار الأول: نوصل إلى اتفاق مشترك
لكم مصالحكم ولي مصالحي
خلونا نلعب على المصالح المشتركة
ما تبغون هذا السيناريو فالمواجهة هي المصير
ليش المواجهة وش نهايتها؟ ليس القضاء على الطرف الآخر
بل الوصول إلى الحل الأول
خلونا نتفق على محاورنا، خلونا نتفق على مصالحي ومصالحك
وبناءً عليها نوصل إلى اتفاق ونتصالح
أنا المملكة العربية السعودية ما أقدر أطلع من المنطقة
وأشيل عفشي وأروح مكان ثاني
أنا ما أقدر
أنا في هذه المنطقة، إيران جنبي تركيا جنبي هذا واقع، لازم نتصالح
بس نبني علاقتنا ونصلّحها بشكل صحيح
2016 الأمير محمد بن سلمان في البداية لما جاء كان عنده خيارين
أنت بتتكلم الحين عن خيارين في إدارة المشهد كله
2016 يا طويل العمر كان لديك خيارين
الخيار الأول إنك تجي بناءً على القواعد الموجودة لديك
تتعامل مع الواقع السياسي
وتعطي هذه الدول مصالحها
تعطي الأطراف اللي موجودة في الداخل مصالحها
تعطي الجميع مصالحها، وتمشِّي الدنيا
وتحاول إنك تتعامل بالواقعية السياسية
الخيار الثاني: تنظِّف الساحة وتبدأ من جديد
الأمير محمد بن سلمان كان قراره الأساسي أنه أنا أروح للخيار الثاني
شلون؟
هذه متشعبة شوي
في البداية مسألة رؤية المملكة 2030 في الداخل
لما وضع الرؤية أنت تضع الرؤية، يا بِناءً على واقعك، يا بناءً على أحلامك
الأمير ماذا اختار؟
الأمير كان حالم
لما طلع في لقاء تركي الدخيل كان لقاء حالم
وكل من كان يسمع ذلك اللقاء في ذلك الوقت كان يرى أنه هذا كلام كبير جدًا
ستواجه الفساد، سأقضي على الجميع
هذا كان كلام حالم  في ذلك الوقت وفق الواقعية السياسية
راح أصنع اقتصاد غير معتمد على النفط
هذا كان حالم جدًا
راح أسوّي المؤسسات
راح يصير فيه مساواة في توزيع الثروة
راح يصير فيه استمرارية واستدامة وديمومة في الاقتصاد وما إلى ذلك
هذه كلها كانت أفكار حالمة
الأمير حط الرؤية قدامه، صنع الرؤية على خياله
ووضعها على الطاولة، ثم قال: سأطوّع الواقع السياسي من أجلها
عكس لما يجيك شخص يقولك لا، أنا أبغى أبني رؤية على الواقع السياسي
أمير على خياله قدّّم هذه الرؤية، وقال يلا
طيب عندك الرؤية الآن
في شيء اسمه مُكبّلات القرار السياسي
أنا اليوم لما أتخذ قرار
وش الأشياء اللي تكبّلني ما أتخذه؟
بدأ يفسر وش هي مكبلات القرار السياسي
أول شغلة لا يصلح الله ما بقومٍ حتى يصلحوا ما بأنفسهم
بدأ معركته الأولى داخل أجهزة الدولة
داخل الدائرة المقربة فيه
داخل مؤسسات الدولة الرئيسية، وبدأ ينظفها من الفساد
هذه ما كانت معلنة بشكل علني، توّنا ما جينا ريتز كارلتون
وبدأ يُقيّم أهلية هذولاء الوزراء، الأمير لما طلع مع عبدالله المديفر ماذا كان يقول؟
كان يقول كنت متفاجئ أنه فيه بعض الوزراء ما أعينهم في أصغر شركة
وكان صادق
الآن عندي المعيار، معيار أنه أنا لازم كل اللي حولي لازم يكونون كفاءة
أوقّف كل مكبلات القرار اللي ممكن تكون داخل مؤسستي
بعدين بنتقل للدائرة الأوسع
نحن الآن 2016
أول مُكبِّل كان وجود القوى المسيطرة على المشهد في السعودية
عندنا تيار إسلام سياسي
اليوم لما أبغى أفتح سينما عشان تجيب لي فلوس
تيار الإسلام السياسي راح يستخدمها
وراح يضغط علي في منعي من استخدام هذه الثروة
اليوم لما أبغى أصنع مسرح، أبغى أصنع موسم الرياض
عندي تيار الإسلام السياسي قاعد يتاجر بهذه القضايا
قضية قيادة المرأة للسيارة، وهي قضية تافهة كان يتاجر بها وكان يلقى إقبال
قيادة المرأة للسيارة هي قضية مقارنةً بهذه القضايا لا شيء
كانت الدولة ما تقدر تحلها لأنه كان فيه رأي عام
قدرة تيار الإسلام السياسي في ذلك الوقت
كانت قدرة إعلامية هائلة، كان عندهم قنوات تلفزيونية
كان عندهم دعم خارجي، كان كان
بالتالي
القرار الأول أنا لازم أواجه هذه المؤسسة أو التيار الإسلام السياسي
أواجه بماذا؟
هل هذه الحرب كانت حرب ضد المؤسسة الدينية؟
أم حرب ضد تيارات الإسلام السياسي؟
هذه الحرب فعليًا كانت ضد تيارات الإسلام السياسي
واستخدم الأمير بل كانت المؤسسة الدينية تقف مع الأمير في هذه الحرب
المؤسسة الدينية السعودية
على الدوام عبر تاريخها ما كانت مؤسسة ضد الحكم
عبر تاريخها
في عهد محمد بن سعود كانت تحت الدولة
عندما سقطت الدولة السعودية الأولى قعدنا تقريبًا سبع سنوات
هذه المؤسسة لم تطلب السلطة وما راحت دوّرت حُكم لأنها لا تستطيع أنها تدوّر حُكم
لأنه مو من ضمن أدبياتها أن تبحث عن الحُكم إطلاقًا
من أدبياتها أن تكون تحت حُكم وترشده وتنصحه بالسر وتتعاون معه
جئنا الدولة السعودية الثانية بكل سنواتها
سقطت الدولة السعودية الثانية، قعدنا إحدى عشر سنة
هذه المؤسسة الدينية لم تستطع أن تنشئ حُكمًا
أو لم ترغب أو لم تستطع إنشاء حُكم لأنها ما تبغى
لأنه ليس من ضمن أدبياتها
عندما جاء الملك عبدالعزيز
أول تحدي كان أحداث السبلة، فتنة السبلة، كانت فتنة دينية
كان فيه إسلام سياسي، وكان فيه المؤسسة الدينية وقفت مع الملك عبدالعزيز ضد السبلة
عهد الملك خالد كان عندنا حادثة جهيمان
المؤسسة الدينية أصدرت بيان أنها ضد الفرقة المارقة اللي دخلت في الحرم المكي
ووقفت مع الدولة في هذه المعركة
1990 حرب الخليج
المؤسسة الدينية ممثلة بالشيخ ابن باز والشيخ ابن عثيمين وقفوا مع الدولة
ضد تيارات الإسلام السياسي في هذه المعركة
2005-2004 لما صارت أحداث الإرهاب المؤسسة الدينية هي بذاتها تصدت لهذا المشهد
المؤسسة الدينية واجهت الربيع العربي داخل السعودية
لما طلع الملك عبدالله في خطابه الشهير
وقال أشكر علماء الأمة وعلماء الإسلام الربانيين
في داخل هيئة كبار العلماء وخارجها
لأنه المؤسسة الدينية فعلًا وقفت مع الدولة في ذلك الزمن
المؤسسة الدينية في 2017 هي جزء من هذه الحرب، وامتداد لكل هذا السياق
في سياقات منذ الدولة السعودية الأولى مرورًا بهذا الوقت
لذلك الأمير واجه تيار الإسلام السياسي
كان فيه تيارات أخرى
كان فيه مثلًا التيار الليبرالي اعتقد بأنّ هذا انتصارًا له
بينما في الواقع لم يكن انتصارًا له
كان انتصار لموقف الدولة القديم
وموقف الدولة الثابت من هذه القضية
لذلك خرج الملك سلمان في خطاب الشورى الشهير الذي تحدث «لا انحلال ولا تشدد»
ما نبغى لا مُفجّر ولا نبغى فاجر
نحن بالنص
هنا بدأ طبعًا إذا اصطدمت بتيار الإسلام السياسي في السعودية هذا يعني بالضرورة
أنك ستصطدم بداعميه في الخارج
بالضرورة
لأن داعميه في الخارج منذ زمن طويل يستثمرون ودائمًا هذه لعبة سياسية
بمعنى اللي يقدر يتدخل فيك ولا يتدخل هذا عنده مشكلة سياسية
هذه لغة السياسة
عشان ما نكون
أنا ما أنا بوزير خارجية أطلع لك وأقول والله نحن ضد التدخل في الدول الخارجية
أنا أقول في السياسة أمريكا إذا رأت فرصة للتدخل ستتدخل
لأنه إذا ما تدخلت فهذه فرصة قدامك
وأنت كسياسي براقماتي لازم تتدخل
فهم تدخلوا فيك لأنه كان عندك فرصة
من خلال التيار الإسلام السياسي
ومو فقط هم بنجي للتيارات الأخرى
فبدأت هذه المواجهة الشرسة مع تيار الإسلام السياسي
أرجعك للرؤية، عندي مشروع اقتصادي شلون ابنيه؟
لازم أشيل الفساد
جملة مرة كبيرة
ومعركة كسر عظم
الأمير محمد بن سلمان عندما دخل هذه المعركة هو يدرك أنها معركة كسر عظم
ويدرك أنّ هذه المعركة خطيرة عليه وخطيرة على القارب أو القيادة التي يقودها
لأنها مواجهة كسر عظم حقيقية
هذه المعركة عندما تدخلها ستدخلها وحيدًا
ليه؟
لأنه ما في أحد راح يتحمّل
أنه يدخل في معركة زي هذه
لكن إذا انتصرت فيها الكل سيكون خلفك
إذا حسمت المعركة
والأمير اليوم حاسمها
فبالتالي الكل وقف خلف ظهره
حتى من كان مترددًا ، حتى الدول التي كانت مترددة ما تبغى تدخل في صراع كهذا
كلهم أدركوا المعركة حُسمَت
فالأمير دخل في مواجهة الفساد، الفساد ماذا يعني؟
يعني مؤسسات الدولة، يعني بيروقراطية
يعني شخصيات متنفذة، يعني تجار
يعني شبكة علاقات يعني يعني
مواجهة هذولاء فأنت تواجه شيء يمتلك قوة تاريخية ويمتلك نفوذ ومصلحة وفلوس
هنا لما فتح الأمير محمد بن سلمان رتز كارلتون.
كانت معركة ليلةٌ ليلاه
لأنه بدأ في مواجهة الإرهاب
أو هو فعلًا الفساد الإرهاب
مواجهة الفساد بهذه الصورة وبهذه الطريقة
وقال للجميع أنه هذه معركة
لن يمنعني عنها إلا ماذا؟ إلا الموت
لأنه هو يدرك بأنها فعلًا معركة خطيرة
وهي معركته معركة شخصية
لأنه يريد أن يصنع هذه الرؤية التي صنعها من خياله
فيريد أن يتم تطويع الواقع السياسي عليها
طبعًا هنا تدخل أيضًا المصالح الاقتصادية
أيضًا فيه دول تدعم هذولاء التجار
فيه دول يدعمون هؤلاء رجال  الأعمال أو أو أو
فيه مصالح مو لازم دول، أيضًا رجال أعمال في الخارج
هذا كله يعرضك لأخطار مختلفة
هذا اللي يفسر لك ليش صارت 2017 سنة انفجار حقيقي
لأنه كانت معركة كسر عظم فعلية
وما كان عنده خيار إلا هذا الخيار لأنه بنى الرؤية ليس على الواقع السياسي
على ما يريد أن يتم تنفيذه
انتهت هذه المكبلات
قللها، أنهاها
قرر أن يُعيد العلاقة مع كل من دخل معهم في صراع
طيب معليش خليك في هذه المرحلة
الحين دخول المعركة
أنت تعرف أنه هذا الكلام حساس
إيه بس أنا بعطيك سؤال عام، وأنت شوف كيف تقدر تلعب بالغابة
ياالله تفضل
وش آثاره؟
الأكيد أنه ما كانت حرب يدخلها، أو معركة تدخلها بدون آثار
ودّي أعرف آثار هذه المعارك، سواءً في تيار الإسلام السياسي أو حتى في الداخل مع الفساد
وش اللي حصل عليه؟
برجّعك للصراع للأبعد، اللي هو صراع الدول هذه
إيران وتركيا، ممتاز؟
إيران، السعودية واجهت تيار الإسلام السياسي
الموجود في السعودية، تيار الإسلام السياسي الشيعي، العوامية بالتحديد
المسوّرة بتحديد أقرب
الأمير محمد بن سلمان قرر أن ينهي أزمة المسوّرة
وأن ينقذ أهالي القطيف، وأن ينقذ السعودية من شيء كان مؤرق دائمًا
إرهاب يستمر ويقتل جنودنا ويقتل الناس المارة
ويخطف علماء أجلاء
زي القاضي الشيعي الجيراني
أنا ناسي اسمه صراحةً، لكن
المقصد أنه هذا راح يوتّر علاقتك مع إيران، ووترها فعلًا وانقطعت العلاقة بسبب
مواجهة الإسلام السياسي الشيعي داخل السعودية
وهذا قطع علاقتك مع تركيا
لأنك أوقفت كل الإسلام السياسي السني الموجود داخل السعودية
وخرّب علاقتك مع تركيا بشكل واضح
رغم أنه العلاقة خربانة من فترة ولّا؟
هي خربانة بس ما وصلت إلى مرحلة سيئة جدًا
يعني المرحلة هذه أنك أنت فعلًا جففت كل المنابع تمامًا
هذه تركيا فيه أحد غيره؟
تركيا وقطر طبًعا
بطبيعة الحال يعني هذا الصراع
بس قطر عاملها الأمير محمد بن سلمان بشكل مختلف
ليش؟
الأمير محمد سلمان في تصريحه للمجلة الأمريكية
ماذا قال عندما سُئل عن أزمة قطر؟
قال هذه أزمة عائلية وحليناها بيننا وبين بعض
وإنه الشيخ تميم الآن هو صديق شخصي لي
ونشاهد اليوم في كأس العالم الأمير محمد بن سلمان يحضر بنفسه إلى كأس العالم
يجعل الحكومة تدعم قطر في كل ما تريده من أجل تذليل الصعوبات أمام كأس العالم
نشاهد في القمة العربية الأخيرة الضحكات وكيف العلاقة
واضح أنها أصبحت علاقة صحية بين السعودية وقطر
وأنا أعتقد أنه العلاقة السعودية القطرية الآن
هي في أفضل مراحلها في تاريخ البلدين
على الإطلاق لأنها أُصلحت
أُصلحت بشكل سليم
عرفتو وش لكم وعرفنا وش لنا
ونحن في النهاية أبناء عمومة وفي قارب واحد
اللي بيجري عليكم بيجري علينا
فبالتالي أصلحنا هذه العلاقة
لما وصلنا بعدين مع تركيا
تركيا أيضًا حسبتها
طيب قبل إصلاح قطر
هل كانت المشكلة الأساسية هي دعم تيار الإسلام السياسي؟
طبعًا مشكلة أساسية دعم تيار الإسلام السياسي
فبناءً على انتفاء هذه المسببات، انتفت معها كل
وعليها تمت المقاطعة وعليها تمت
عليها تم كل شيء
وهذه أعتقد أنها جزء من التاريخ
سيأتي يوم توثّق بشكل مُفصّل عبدالرحمن
تركيا؟
تركيا وصلت إلى قناعة
تركيا طبعًا أنت لازم برضه تحسب إنه أردوغان الحين وش الحسبة اللي عنده
أردوغان عند انتخابات قادمة، وضع اقتصادي سيء
هذا في ذيك الفترة
وضع اقتصادي سيء، فقد مصر
فقد تونس بوجود قيس سعيّد
فقد ليبيا وانسحب، سحب قواته من ليبيا على الأقل جزء كبير منها
دافع اقتصادي ولّا سياسي؟
بدافع اقتصادي، اقتصاده أصبح منهك جدًا
متأزِّم، وبدافع ردة فعل سياسية لأنه في مصر فقد نفوذه في مصر
بسبة الجيش المصري اتخذ موقف
أيضًا في تونس نفس الشيء، الرئيس قيس سعيد هو الذي أخرجهم
فهذا هو الصراع السياسي، بغض النظر أنت تحبه تكرهه
هذا هو واقع سياسي صار في تونس
فأردوغان لما حسبها بالورقة والقلم على مايقولون
هو فقد كثير من أوراقه
الآن يريد أن يعود الى عام ما قبل 2003
صفِّر مشاكلي مع الجميع لأنه عندي الآن انتخابات قادمة واقتصاد سيء
أستفيد من علاقة جيدة مع السعودية، السعودية فاتحة يدها بشكل واضح لتركيا
تقول الخيار الأول
تعرف مصالحي وأعرف مصالحك ونتفاهم مع بعض
تبغى الخيار هذا حيّاك الله، ما تبغى عندنا خيار المواجهة
فأردوغان عاد للخيار الأول لأنه وجد إنه في السعودية قيادة
تريد أن تحافظ على مصالحها ومصالح العالم العربي
هذا يسري أيضًا على الحوثي اللي راح نجيه مع التصالح مع إيران
في ظل هذا الدربكة هذه صارت الأحداث الروسية الأوكرانية
صحى بوتين من النوم قرر إنه يغزو أوكرانيا، تغيّر شكل العالم، جميل؟
وتغيّرت أيضًا موازين القوى في العالم
أصبح النفط سلعة مهمة للغاية
اكتشف العالم أنه العولمة تسببت له بأزمة كبيرة
العولمة أنه ربط العالم بالعالم سبب أزمة كبيرة
فيه جزء من العالم ينهار، يصاب العالم بالشلل
هذه الأزمة يا طويل العمر خلقت معنا التيار اليميني
طبعًا التيار اليميني من قبله، لكن صار بشكل واضح
أن الكل أصبح يبحث عن مصلحته
مصلحته القومية وما إلى ذلك
السعودية استغلت هذا المشهد استغلال مثالي
قالت أنا الآن أبغى أحافظ على مصالحي
لما وصلنا إلى اتفاق أوبك بلس
بين السعودية وروسيا ودول أوبك
أهم الدول المعترضة على هذا الاتفاق أمريكا
السعودية بشكل واضح أصلحت علاقتها مع أمريكا
قالت أنه أنا عندي مصلحتي
هذه المسألة لا تناقشوني فيها الآن، مسألة النفط
مسائل أخرى راح نتعاون فيها، أنتم حلفائنا
من زمن روزفيلت مرورًا إلى اليوم
بناءً على هالحادثة هذه
استطاعت السعودية أن تكسب أيضًا
ثِقل وأهمية عند روسيا والصين
روسيا والصين كبّلوا إيران سياسيًا وعسكريًا
شلون كبّلوا إيران سياسيًا وعسكريًا؟
طلع لك المتحدث السعودي في الأمم المتحدة
وقال أنه روسيا والصين ضغطت على إيران
لإيقاف قصف السعودية وإيقاف أنه الحوثي يُلحق الضرر بالسعودية
هذا تصريح رسمي وموجود في وكالة رويترز
الإيرانيين
عام كم؟
هذا قريب هذا بعد اتفاق أوبك بلس
الإيرانيين يا طويل العمر وجدوا أنهم أمام سد
والسعودية فاتحة يدها من زمان
من 2015 لما السعودية قادت معركتها ضد الحوثي
ثاني شهر رفعت مبادرة
تعالوا نتصالح ونتحاور، نحن سوينا الحرب هذه عشان نتحاور مو عشان نقضي عليكم
راحوا يتفاوضون في الكويت، بعدين راحوا يتفاوضون في جنيف
وبعدين راحوا يتفاوضون في أمستردام
راحوا يتفاوضون في مناطق مختلفة في العالم، في السويد
فالسعودية عندها أكثر من مبادرة للصلح مع الحوثي والصلح مع إيران
إنه نرجعكم للخيار الأول؛ مصالحي ومصالحك وخل نتفاهم مع بعض
تبغى تتواجه واجهناك
هنا إيران اضطرت يا طويل العمر
إنها تغيّر سياستها
هنا صار التدخل الصيني
الصين لما أقول لك الاقتصاد دائمًا يؤثر على المعادلة
الصين بالنسبة لها السعودية  هي المُصدِّر رقم واحد للنفط والطاقة
الصين بالنسبة لها أيضًا هذا الجانب بعيد شوي
أي إعادة إعمار في المنطقة
راح تستفيد منها الشركات الصينية
خصوصًا إذا كان هي لها دور فيها
الصين تواصلت مع السعودية
في زيارة الرئيس الصيني الشهيرة
وقالوا للسعوديين نحن نبغى ندخل وساطة بينكم وبين الإيرانيين
السعودية قالت من البداية أنا ما عندي مشكلة
أنا موقفي واضح
يبغون نتفق اتفاق بعدم إضرار بمصالح الأخرين وما إلى ذلك
نحن فاتحيين يدينا
رجع الرئيس الصيني إلى بكين
تواصل مع الرئيس الإيراني رئيسي
وفعلًا الرئيس سافر له
قال له بصريح العبارة
أنه بالنسبة لي السعودية هي أولوية
إلحاق الضرر بالسعودية ممنوع
أنا يا الرئيس الصيني
عندي الآن مصالح معك يا إيران
وأنا موقّع معك اتفاقية 25 سنة اقتصادية
وأنا أكبر مستثمر في إيران
كل الأشياء هذه رح تضرر
إذا ما تعاملت مع السعودية بشكل جيد
ووصلتوا إلى حل
الرئيس الإيراني وإيران
ما لقوا قدامهم حل إلا أنهم يوافقون على هذا العرض الصيني
وهذا اللي تم
توجّه مساعد العيبان، توجّه مستشار الأمن القومي الإيراني إلى إيران
واتفقوا على هذا الاتفاق اللي شفناه كلنا
هذا الاتفاق سرى عليه اتفاقات مختلفة بعده
العلاقة مع سوريا
التفاوض مع الحوثيين، رغم أنه التفاوض مع الحوثيين ماله دخل بإيران بشكل مباشر
ليش ماله دخل بإيران؟
الحوثي وإيران علاقتهم توترت من بعد معركة مأرب
معركة مأرب يا طويل العمر
الاقتصاد الإيراني كان يعاني معاناة كبيرة
فبالتالي تواصلوا مع الحوثيين
إنه نحن ما راح نقدر ندفعلكم خلال الأشهر هذه
لا فلوس ولا سلاح ولا ولا
الحوثيين قرروا أنهم يهاجمون مأرب عشان يستفيدون من حقول النفط اللي موجودة هناك
ويشتغلون عليها كذلك في الضغط لتمرير قضية دفع الرواتب وما إلى ذلك
كل الإعلام الغربي في ذلك الوقت كان يقول إنه مأرب ساقطة عسكريًا
حتى وكالات الاستخبارات العالمية كانت تقول إن مأرب وفق لغة الأرقام
أو لغة الواقع السياسي ساقطة
السعودية دخلت في معركة طويلة في مأرب
استعدت سياسيًا واستعدت عسكريًا
ساعدت أيضا اليمنيين في هذه المعركة لمواجهة الحوثي في مأرب، وفعلًا انتصروا في مأرب
وتم ردع الحوثي
الحوثي من بعد هذه المعركة أدرك بأنه القواعد بدأت تتغير شيئًا فشيئًا
فبالتالي هو راح يجلس على الطاولة الآن
بس هذا الجلوس بطبيعة الحال
العقلية اليمنية عقلية صعبة جدًا
ليس فقط الحوثي
الحوثي، الشرعية، الانتقالي
جميع الفاعلين السياسيين اليوم في اليمن
طريقتهم السياسية وتفكيرهم السياسي صعب للغاية
صعب للغاية في إيجاد حلول
لذلك هذه الأزمة اليمنية الفعلية سببها
النخبة اليمنية السياسية من كل الأطراف لديها حالة من التعنُّت عجيب
فبالتالي هذه الأزمة راح تطول إذا ما قدرنا نتعامل مع هذه العقلية في التفكير
ونوصلهم إلى حل جيد، لذلك السعودية تقول أنا الآن سأكون وسيط
معكم وراح أحاول أحل لكم هذه القضية
راح أجلسكم على طاولة، لازم تتحاورون لأنه الحوار هو السبيل الوحيد
الحرب ما راح تجيب نتيجة
بسبب هذا الاتفاق السعودي الإيراني
صارت حالة التهدئة القادمة هذه
ممتاز، طيب أنا ودّي أفهم بعض الأشياء
إذا نبغى نفهمها نفهمها من منطلق كيف تفكر الرياض إذا نبغى نخليه بهذا الشكل
في علاقتها مع أمريكا نبدأ فيها لأنه هو الحليف الأقدم
واضح إنها تتغيّر وخصوصًا نظرة الأمريكان للمنطقة
بعزو برضه لأوباما وانسحابه من المنطقة
ونظرته برضه للسعودية والقوى الموجودة
فكيف تنظر اليوم الرياض لأمريكا
وهو الحليف الأقدم الأقوى؟
يبدو لي أنه تصريح الأمير فيصل بن تركي
كحيلان النصر اسم صديقنا لأنه ينطبق تمامًا على أمريكا
فعلًا ما صديقنا إلا لنا، الأمريكان صديقهم هو المصلحة
نحن كيف تفكر الرياض اتجاه أمريكا؟
الرياض ترى بأنه أمريكا حليف
وحليف استراتيجي منذ عهد الملك عبد العزيز إلى يومنا الحالي
هذا الحليف مرت علاقتنا مع بصعود وهبوط
عبر التاريخ
والصعود والهبوط مرة هم فعلًا كانت مصالحهم تتقاطع معنا
ومصالح متفقين نحن وياهم، ومرة لا نختلف
لكن الفترة الحالية هي أوضح فترة لأنه الأمير قرر أنه يصلح هذه العلاقة بشكل واضح
أنه الأمير محمد بن سلمان والمملكة العربية السعودية بشكل عام ترى بأنه
لا يجب أن يتم ارتهان العلاقة السعودية الأمريكية
لنتائج الانتخابات الأمريكية
يجي رئيس نضطر نبني من جديد
كل الأشياء اللي نتفق عليها
كل رئيس الانتخابات يطلع ويتكلم عن وعود، وأنه سيحاسب السعودية
على حقوق الإنسان وما إلى ذلك
بس في النهاية هذه الحالة مربكة لأي علاقة طبيعية
السعودية ترى بأنه على الأمريكان إنه تُصلح أو خلونا نقعد مع بعض  ونُصلح علاقتنا مع بعض
مو كل ما صار عندكم انتخابات صارت عندنا أزمة بيننا وبينكم
على هذا المنوال
السعودية الآن أوصلت العلاقة الأمريكية السعودية إلى هذه الحالة
أنا أعتقد الحالة الحالية إنها حالة صحية
بدأت تصبح حالة صحية
كيف؟
بعد ما توترت العلاقة معهم لأنهم اكتشفوا أنه نحن صاملين في موقف
ما راح نفرّط في مصالحنا، الاتفاق مع إيران نحن خبرناهم
حسب الروايات الرسمية أنه السعودية خبرتهم بشكل رسمي قبل إعلان هذا الاتفاق
لأنهم حلفاؤنا، لكن هذا هو قرارنا
أنه راح نتصالح مع إيران
وهذا هو قرارنا أنه راح نتفق مع روسيا على موضوع أوبك
واتفاقنا مع روسيا على موضوع أوبك لا يعني أننا ارتمينا في حضن روسيا وتركناكم
ولما نتصالح أو نطور علاقتنا الاقتصادية مع الصين هذا لا يعني أنه نحن نعاديكم
نحن في نفس الفترة بين وبينكم صفقات مليارية
سواءً على الطائرات المدنية اللي وُقعت قبل فترة
أو على المشاريع الكبرى، على التقنيات التي تأخذها السعودية من أمريكا
فعلاقتنا يجب أن تكون صحية
لذلك الأمير محمد بن سلمان عندما ظهر في القمة العربية الأخيرة
في مطلع كلمته ماذا قال؟
فلنوجّه رسالتنا للشرق والغرب أنه مصالحنا هي أولوية ولن نسمح بأنه تتدخلون
في العالم العربي بطريقة سلبية وما إلى ذلك
فهو أصلح علاقته معهم بهذه الصورة
هل يستوعب الأمريكان هذه الحالة الجديدة؟
أعتقد أنهم بدأوا يستوعبون
لذلك تغيرت لغة الخطاب بشكل كبير
أشخاص كُثر كانوا ينتقدون الأمير محمد بن سلمان
من أعضاء الكونقرس
شفناهم قبل أيام ملتقين فيه
كانوا يقولون ردًا على الإعلام إنه أنتم كنتم تنتقدون الرجل، شلون وصلتوا له الآن؟
قالوا والله شفنا البلد تتغيّر
وفعليًا شافوا إنه الواقع
أكثر جدية وأكثر وضوحًا
وإنه هو سيناريو وحيد
هذه هي العلاقة اللي بيني وبينكم
فالحالة اللي وصلتها السعودية الآن
السياسية هي حالة صحية للغاية في علاقاتنا الخارجية
حالة تتجه إلى الصحية مع إيران
حالة تتجه إلى الصحية مع أردوغان
حالة تتجه إلى الصحية مع العالم العربي
وحالة التجارة الصحية مع روسيا وأمريكا والصين والجميع
طيب الصين
برضه كيف تنظر لها الرياض؟
هل هو كحليف بديل لأمريكا؟ حليف أخر؟
هل تسمح أصلًا أمريكا لوجود
السعودية لا تفكر بإيجاد حليف أوحد
والعقلية السعودية الحالية لا تفكر إطلاقًا بإيجاد حليف أوحد
السعودية تقول أنا وين ما تروح مصلحتي أنا معها
الجميع حلفائي
الصين أنا أكبر مورِّد له في الطاقة
والصين قاعدة أيضًا تزودني بتقنيات، تزودني بالشركات الصينية
اللي قاعدة تشتغل في السعودية
أمريكا في المقابل أيضًا نفس الفكرة
وروسيا نفس الفكرة
صراعكم مع بعض أنا مالي علاقة فيه
هذا نفس اللي سواه الملك عبدالعزيز
لما جاء على الطائرات الإيطالية والألمان والحلفاء
صراعكم هذا أنا مالي دخل فيه
أنا عندي موقف واضح، بناءً عليه يا جماعة الخير
تعاملوا معي الرجال عندي مصلحتي
وأنا أبغى أصنع قوة اقتصادية اليوم في المنطقة، في الشرق الأوسط
وكذلك أساهم في تنمية المنطقة بشكل عام
من خلال إخماد المشاكل وإخماد الحروب
وإصلاح العلاقات البينية بين الدول
فيه ناس تجي تقول أنت الحين
بعد الرواية للي حصل وكيف طلعت النتايج
بس يجي يقول لك
دخلنا في حرب أو في عراك مع إيران
وفي الأخير بعد كل هذا
رجعنا للنقطة الأساسية اللي بدينا عليهم فما تغيّر شيء
دخلنا مع قطر وخرجنا وما تغيّر شيء
دخلنا في حرب مع اليمن علشان ننهي الحوثي ولا يزال الحوثي موجود
فكل العراك دخلنا مع تركيا في المشاكل
وأردوغان لا يزال موجود
فما تغيّر شيء في المشهد
من قال ما تغيّر شيء؟
فيظهر شلون يصير إنه ما تغيّر
إنه ما صار شيء
مثلًا بشار لا زال هو الرئيس ونحن تخاصمنا معه
تخاصمنا مع إيران لا تزال هي نفسها نفسها
قطر
ففي الشكل العام أنه وين المكاسب؟
وين المكاسب؟
المعيار نفسه وش هو؟
أول شيء نحن تخاصمنا معهم وتحاربنا معهم لنقضي عليهم؟
لا
هذه قلت أنا قبل شوي
نحن ما دخلنا معهم في صراع لنقضي عليهم
نحن دخلنا في صراع معهم لكي نعيدهم إلى قواعد سليمة في العلاقة الثنائية
تركيا ما قبل الصراع ليست كتركيا ما بعد الصراع
تركيا قبل الصراع كانت مسيطرة على يعني تقريبا 60% من العالم العربي
من خلال الأحزاب الموجودة
تركيا اليوم ليس لديها نفوذ في مصر، وليس لديها نفوذ في تونس
ليس لديها نفوذ في  في ليبيا مثلًا بشكل كبير
ليس لديها نفوذ في سوريا لأنها بدأت تتصالح مع بشار
وستتعامل معه بطريقة أخرى
تركيا قبل الأزمة ليست كما بعد الأزمة
إيران
إيران قبل الأزمة كان لديها نفوذ في البحرين
كان لديها نفوذ واسع في اليمن
نحن خلال عاصفة الحزم قلّصنا التواجد الإيراني
الحوثي كان محتل 100%، محتل اليمن بالكامل
الآن الحوثي لا يحتل إلا 30%
هذا يعني أنّ هنالك شيء تغيّر
ونفس الفكرة قطر، قطر استثناء  نحن نعاملها معاملة العائلة الواحدة
لذلك الأمير محمد بن سلمان عندما قال أنه هذه مشكلة عائلية
فهي مشكلة عائلية عائلية تم حلَّها
والعلاقة أصبحت صحية للغاية الآن
فإنك تقول ما في شيء تغيّر هذه مو بصحيح
أنك تقول نحن دخلنا معهم حرب
لأنه بنقضي عليهم وهذا مو بصحيح
نحن ما دخلنا لنقضي عليهم
نحن دخلنا لنعيدهم إلى الصيغة الأصلح
والصيغة الأصح للعلاقة الصحية فيما بيننا
هذا هو المعيار اللي لازم تقرأ من خلاله الأحداث
إذا راح تقرأ الأحداث في العالم العربي خارج سياق المخاض اللي صاير
لن تفهم شيء
المقصد إذا أنت تصالحت مع إيران وصفّرت المشاكل
فأنت لاشك كل من يسري على ذلك راح تتصالح معه
القوى الثلاثة السعودية، تركيا، إيران
الصراع اللي أدخلوه الآن هم كلهم أدركوا إنه ولا واحد منهم يقدر يقضي على الآخر
فيه أشخاص أو فيه أطراف كانت تريد أن تقضي على الأطراف الأخرى
وفيه أطراف لا كانت تريد أن تُصلح العلاقة
نحن وجهة نظرنا أنه لازم يا جماعة الخير
نحن بنقاومكم
نحن ما راح نخليكم تأخذون العالم العربي
ما راح نخليكم تأخدون مصالحنا وبنقاومكم
لمقصد أنه لازم نصلّح علاقتنا مع بعض
الطرف الإيراني فترة من الفترات كان شعاره القضاء على الأطراف الأخرى
فالمقصد أنه الأطراف الثلاثة طالما
طيب كيف تفسر إيران اليوم أنها أقالت مهندس صفقة
ما عندي صراحة معلومات كثيرة عن الموضوع هذا
ربما أنه فيه شيء داخلي بينهم بس إلا ما تكشّفت
هل أحد يقرأ أنه إيران فعلًا جالسة تتغيّر؟
طيب ما هي الضمانة، ما هي ضمانة هذا الاتفاق بين السعودية وإيران؟
ما أدري
الصين
السعودية تثق في الصين
بالتالي تعتبر ضامن لهذه العلاقة الثنائية
وإيران بتسمع كلام الصين؟
إيران إلى الآن سامعة كلام الصين
عندك سعودي يخطف قبل يومين في بيروت
يطلع بعدها بأقل من ساعة
مو بأقل من يوم يعني، ممتاز؟
الدولة اللبنانية حتى حزب الله، لو تشوف إعلام حزب الله كان ينتقد الحاجة هذه
وش اللي تغيّر؟
اللي تغيّر إنه هم أصلًا ملتزمين الآن بهذا الاتفاق حاليًا
يطلع لك الإعلام السوري الآن يمتدح السعودية
يمتدح رؤية 2030
وش اللي تغيّر؟
الإعلام العراقي المحسوب على اتحاد الإذاعات الإسلامية
وهو المدعوم من قِبل إيران
كل قنواتهم قاعدة تمدح السعودية
وش اللي تغيّر؟
نحن ليش دائمًا ننظر أنه نحن اللي تغيّرنا، وهم ما تغيّروا يعني؟
الواقع كله تغيّر عبدالرحمن
صحيح
فهذا هو الواقع السياسي
أنا أرى أنه السياسة السعودية الحالية طوّعت الواقع السياسي لما تريد
طوّعت الواقع السياسي ولم تتعامل مع الواقع السياسي كأمر واقع، والشكوى لله
وخلونا نمشي ونحاول نمشّيها
طيب كيف بيكون وضع العراق؟
وهو في هذا المعترك؟
أنا أعتقد أنه العراق حاليًا سيكون مستفيد للغاية من الصلح السعودي الإيراني، للغاية
ليه؟ لأنه السعودية الآن قاعدة تدفع باتجاه أنه نحن راح نساهم معكم يا العراقيين
في تنمية العراق من خلال المشاريع المشتركة
ممتاز؟ إيران كذلك تريد أن تستثمر في العراق
في الموضوع الاقتصادي
إذا الطرفين تنافسوا داخليًا في العراق من أجل الاقتصاد
بيزدهر
بيزدهر العراق
بس هل بينسحب الحرس الثوري، هل بتنسحب الطائفية اللي تعززها إيران؟
ما في حل سحري، عصا سحرية يقول لك يلا طلعهم
من ضمن الاتفاقية طيب كان
أنا أعتقد أنها على المدى البعيد
أنه خصوصًا الشعب العراقي اليوم تغيّر
أعطيك مثال أنا 2019 كنت في بغداد
2019 حضرت مظاهرات تشرين، كنت أغطي مع إم بي سي، جميل؟
الشباب العراقيين الموجودين في بغداد أغلبهم
90% إن لم يكن 100% اللي كانوا موجودين
90% اللي كانوا موجودين في شوارع بغداد كلهم شيعة
شباب شيعة، شعارهم الأساسي كان ضد إيران، ممتاز؟
وأحد الشباب كان قاعد يسولف معي يقول والله إذا هم مخوفينا زمان
بأنه الوهابي الذي خلف الحدود، يقصد السعودي وفق الدعاية الإيرانية
الوهابي اللي خلف الحدود هذا جايني يقتلني
أنا قاعد أشوف الوهابي اللي خلف الحدود هذا قاعد يحتفل بيمدل بيست
قاعد يستمع لأغاني محمد عبده
حاط البندانة وقاعد
فهذا شلون ؟
هذا قاعد يعيش حياته
أنا وش ذنبي أنا؟ أنا لازم أعيش حياتي
أنا ليش أبقى حبيس هذه الخندقة الطائفية إلى الأبد؟
هذه العقلية الشباب الصغار هذولاء، المجتمع المدني اللي بيطلع في العراق هذا
هذا مجتمع وطني
بشكل كبير
شعاراتهم وطنية جدًا
شعاراتهم ضد الطائفية
اليوم لما تتابع خطابهم في تويتر، فيسبوك، إنستقرام
خطاب واعي واعي للغاية
وهذولاء كلهم شباب ولدوا ما بعد 2003
يعني تعوّدوا على الأزمة والحرب هذه ولكن يبغون الخلاص من المسألة
فالعراق بسبب الاتفاق السعودي الإيراني
إذا نجح بإذن الله أنا أعتقد أنه راح يكون منطقة مزدهرة للغاية
وش موقف أمريكا من الاتفاق؟
طبعًا شوف أمريكا
الإعلام الأمريكي غاضب
لكن التصاريح الأمريكية الرسمية ما فيها شيء واضح
غضب أو رضا أو أو
الإعلام الإسرائيلي مثلًا غاضب
ما يبغى هذا الاتفاق
فهذه ملامح قد تعطيك مؤشرات
بطبيعة الحال الاستقرار في المنطقة راح يضر دول كثيرة في العالم
بطبيعة الحال
ليه؟
لأنه حالة الاستقرار لا تخلق فرص
حالة الاستقرار
بالعكس الازدهار برضه بيخلق فرص
الازدهار بيخلق فرص للأشخاص اللي كسبوه وخلصوا
بس لما تجي دولة جديدة تبغى تدخل في هذه المنطقة تضطر أنها تتنافس على معيار السوق
ما تنافس بإيجاد ميليشيات أو تنافس بإيجاد قادة سياسيين فاسدين
يتاقضون أموال من أجل تمرير صفقات
حالة الصراع الموجودة في العالم العربي تخلق فرص يسيل لها اللعاب
وأنا أتمنى أن لا يتجه السودان إلى هذا الاتجاه
بسبب الحرب الحالية
فاللي صاير في السودان هو فتّح عيون بعد
فتّح عيون الجميع أنه عندنا سلة غذاء العالم
بلاد فيها مخزون غذائي هائل، البلد فيها ذهب، بلد فيها ثروات
من اللي راح يأخذها؟
ليش نتركها  لحميدتي ولّا برهان ولّا
فالاستقرار مضر
وش موقف السعودية من السودان؟
موقف السعودية
أول شيء السعودية الآن هدفها الرئيسي يجب أن تتوقف هذه الحرب فورًا
بأي صورةٍ كانت
لذلك السعودية قاعدة تحاول
إنها توقفها بكل الصور
لأنه هذه حرب مالها قيمة
صراع عبثي تمامًا
ولا راح تكون نتائجه لو انتصر الطرفين كل نتائج سيئة
يجب أن يتوقف هذا الحوار، هذا موقف السعودية يجب أن يتوقف
ارجعوا للحوار السياسي
وارجعوا للاتفاق اللي أنتم وقعتوه
وخلونا نسوي حكومة مدنية
وتنتهي الأزمة
هذا موقف السعودية، والسعودية الآن
قلقة للغاية من وجود تدخل أجنبي في المنطقة
لذلك في القمة العربية في بيان القمة العربية
كانت السعودية أو جامعة الدول العربية
تقول يجب أن يقف أو نحاول منع التدخل الخارجي اللي موجود في السودان
خلونا قبل لا يجي لازم نوقفه
هذا خط أحمر
لأنه راح يضر المنطقة كثيرًا لو صار هناك تدخل خارجي
وصراع ومنطقة بالقُرب منا
هذا راح يضر مصر بشكل مباشر
أنت الآن لما تأخذ الموقف المصري ترى موقف صعب للغاية
مصر عندها أزمة في سيناء بوجود الإرهاب
عندها في البحر المتوسط في ذلك الوقت كانت على صراع مع أردوغان في مسألة الغاز
عندها ليبيا على الجهة الغربية محتقنة وفيها حرب
الآن تقوم عليها السودان راح تكون مشكلة
طيب موقف الرياض من جامعة الدول العربية؟
الرياض ترى أنه الجامعة يجب أن تقوم بدورها
وش دورها؟
أرجعك لإصلاح الجامعة العربية
وإصلاح مجلس التعاون الخليجي
شوف آخر قمة في الرياض السعودية قالت أنه عندنا رؤية لإصلاح هذا المجلس
أنه وش القيمة الجامعة العربية إذا ما تؤثر في القرار العربي؟
وش قيمة مجلس التعاون الخليجي
إذا ما يؤثر في العلاقات الخليجية المشتركة؟
فيجب أن يتم إصلاحها
شلون راح يتم اصلاحها؟ هذا هو السؤال الصعب، وهذه معركة ثانية جديدة
لم تبدأ بعد؟
لم تبدأ بعد
أعتقد أنه مشهد قمة جدة
بإتحاد العرب بهذه الصورة
خلف القيادة السعودية بشكل كامل
هو مؤشر خير أنه يجب أن يكون للعرب كتلة
كتلة موجودة في العالم تدافع عن مصالحها وتبحث عن
مصلحة شعوبها بدرجة أولى
بعيدًا عن مصلحة الدول الغربية أو الشرقية
بس يقولك إنه كانت قطر تخالف التطبيع مع بشار
قطر في القرار العام لعودة بشار كانت موافقة
وهذا الموقف الرسمي، قطر تقول أنا ما راح أطلع من الإجماع العربي
قرار عودة بشار بإجماع عربي
لكن قطر تقول العلاقة البينية ما بيني وبين بشار
مو استشار، إجماع؟
إجماع أصلًا نظام جامعة الدول العربية يقول إنه القرارات كلها لازم تكون بالإجماع
خصوصًا القرارات المهمة الرئيسية
لذلك القذافي في 1990 وش كان يقول؟
لما قرروا بدعم السماح بالقوات الأمريكية بدخول الخليج
كان يقول لائحة جامعة الدول العربية تقول بالإجماع
بس هذيك كان لها تكييف قانوني آخر
فكرة الإجماع كانت موجودة في عودة بشار، بما فيها قطر
كانت أيضًا تقول أنا ما أبغى أطلع من الإجماع العربي
لكن العلاقة البينية ما بيني وبين بشار إلى الآن ما زال فيها أشياء معلقة
وهذا يخصهم
والسعودية تقول أنا ما عندي مشكلة
السعودية لا تريد أن تتدخل في علاقات الآخرين بالأخرين
السعودية تقول أي دولة بيكون لها علاقة جيدة في إيران ما عندي مشكلة بس بشرط
إنه ما يكون علاقتك هذه تضرني
بيضير معك علاقة بينك وبين مالي أو موزمبيق
الأردن على علاقة بأي دولةٍ كانت
مالي علاقة، أهم شيء لا يدخل في، يضر مصلحتي الداخلية
وهذا الالتزام الموجود بجامعة الدول العربية بشكل عام
ممتاز، طيب
هل تعتقد أنه السعودية خرجت من هذا كله أقوى؟
طبعًا السعودية الآن بلد قوي للغاية
من ناحية قدرتها على مواجهة المستقبل بشكل أكبر
السعودية الآن اقتصادها تعافى
السعودية الآن عندها جيل شاب كبير
أتكلم عن كل الوزارات الحكومية اليوم كل الوزراء شباب
الطاقة الموجودة في السعودية، حالة التغيير الموجودة في السعودية
اليوم السعودية مقبلة أنا أعتقد الآن بدأت مسيرة جني الثمار إن صح التعبير
فأنا أرى أنه كل اللي تجاوزناه الآن
كانت معارك صعبة للغاية ومعارك كسر عظم
خسرنا فيها وربحنا فيها، أخطأنا فيها وأجدنا فيها
لكن النتيجة العامة هي نتيجة ممتازة
مشهد قمة وصول بايدن إلى جدة هو مشهد انتصار للسعودية
مشهد القمة الصينية هو أيضًا
مشهد انتصار للسعودية
أنه العالم العربي كله خلف السعودية
مشهد قمة جدة كذلك العربية هو
أيضًا استمرار لهذه الحالة
الأمير لما قال في أحد لقاءاته السابقة
قال أنا أريد أن أعيد الشرق الأوسط، أن يكون أوربا الجديدة
كانت جملة حالمة
زي الكلام الذي كان مع تركي الدخيل في بداية الرؤية إنها كانت أيضًا
رؤية حالمة وجملة حالمة
لكن أعتقد أنها الأمير ما قالها إلا هو يقصدها ويعنيها ويريد أن يثبتها
ومن الأشياء الجيدة الأمير يقول هذه التصاريح لتكون
عنصر ضغط كبير في تحقيق هذا الهدف
فأنا أتمنى أنه هذا المشروع ينجح رغم صعوبته، إنه بتحوّل الشرق الأوسط إلى أوربا الجديدة
هذا بشكل عام
ممتاز، أنت الإصلاح عندك
ليس بالضرورة أنه يكون على شكل اتفاقيات ممكن تكون عن طريق حرب
هذا الإصلاح
الإصلاح بخياريه، نعم
كيف تقرأ السبع سنين القادمة، وش الإصلاحات الموجودة؟
أنا أعتقد أنه السبع السنين القادمة على الشرق الأوسط هي مرحلة استقرار
إلى 2030
أنا أرى وجهة نظري من خلال السياق اللي أنا أشوفه أنا دائمًا السياق سيقودني إلى سياق
السياق اللي راح هذا كله سيقودنا إلى سياق ممتاز خلال السبع سنوات القادمة
حالة استقرار سيمر فيها الشرق الأوسط
على الأقل نظريًا وفق المعطيات الموجودة
إنه في حالة استقرار ستمر على الشرق الأوسط
فيه حالة هدوء ستمر على الشرق الأوسط
حالة الهدوء والاستقرار ستخلق لنا مزايا، وستخلق لنا مكاسب كبيرة للغاية
فأنا متفائل ومتفائل للغاية
لو جيتني 2017-2018 بقول لك التفاؤل مو بكبير
إيه مستحيل
لأنه كنا في معركة
لكن الآن التفاؤل كبير
لأنه شفنا مجريات المعركة، وعرفنا مخاضها شلون صار
بناءً عليها أنا أشعر باطمئنان كبير حيال المستقبل
يارب، يعطيك العافية
يعطيك العافية
شكرًا لكم، شكرًا لمنتج هذه الحلقة أيمن الحمادي
والتصوير عبدالرحمن العبود
وفي الهندسة الصوتية محمد الحسن والتحرير محمد نور شمّة
والتلوين عبدالمجيد العطاس
وفي إدارة محتوى التواصل الاجتماعي نورة السبيعي
ومدير التصوير رحاب موسى، وفي إدارة البرنامج أسيل باعبدالله
هذا فنجان أحد منتجات الشركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع
ننشر كل الإنتاج بحب من مدينة الرياض
الأسبوع المقبل ألقاكم
كنت بسألك على قطر والبحرين
شفت إنهم تصالحوا
إيه؟
هم تصالحوا فعلًا؟
هم تصالحوا فعلًا
بوساطة سعودية بشكل مباشر
وش كانت إشكاليتهم؟
هو اللي صالحهم
تصالحوا في مبنى مجلس التعاون الخليجي
جدة ولّا وين؟
اللي على طريق الملك خالد
وكانت مصورة بشكل رسمي انه الجلسات اللي كانت بينهم
اتفاق العُلا وش يقولك؟ اتفاق العُلا يقولك يا طويل العمر
تعالوا نتفق على المبادئ، اتفقنا على المبادئ؟ كل دولة بالعلاقة البينية تصالحوا أنتم مع بعض
وإنه اتفاق العُلا راح يضمن أنه يقود إلى علاقات بينية جيدة
يعني راح نتابع
نقول تعالوا يالبحرين وقطر خلوا نصلح علاقتكم مع بعض
الإمارات قطر المفترض تصلح علاقتكم مع بعض
وتبريد الأزمة، برّد الأزمة على الأقل خلونا نتفق على الآن نبردها نوقف والزمن كفيل بالحل
يا أخي مصطفى فقي لما طلع معي تكلم أنه من أهم مزايا حسني مبارك
وهو كان سكرتير حسني مبارك، يقول أنه يضع الزمن كأحد حلوله
كيف؟
يقول الزمن هذا بعض القضايا يقول والله بحلها بالتدخل
بعض القضايا يقول بكلم فلان عشان يسوي مدري وش هو
بعض القضايا يقول طلع لي الزمن خل الزمن يحلها
خلها لا تجيها لا تقربها، الزمن بيحلها
إنك تعرف تتعامل مع الزمن وتقدر أنك تخليه من ضمن أوراقك اللي تشتغل فيها
ترى إذا عندك مشكلة في ثمانية خلِّ الزمن يحلها